ya
Ben 24 gün içerisinde
otomotiv'e otobüs
operasyonlarından sorumlu
24v dair çok hikayeler var cebinde azdır
hikayesi olur diye yanımda getirdim
Bugün sizlerle paylaşacağım bugün çok
güçlü bir başlığımız var Sesini geliyor
bilmiyorum bu arada
bu ok işareti geldi Orada
iyi mi biraz kurumsal Yemek varsa
biraz da bireysel gibi mimar tarafından
alınan önlemler sizlere anlatmaya
paylaşmaya çalışacağım dediğim gibi
yanında getirdiği başucu hikayesiyle
birlikte de şimdi
önce de çağırdı görselde başlamak
istiyorum Bu bizim 90'ıncı yılda
çıkardığımız kitabı gözleri yani
neredeyse bir asırlık bir şekilde
çalışıyoruz Bu daha çarpıcı kılarsa Asıl
bu diğer bu değerli arkadaşları ettiği
550 Diyanet dünyanın en büyük 500
kuruluşuna yaşam döngüsünü gösterelim
şöyle özetleyeyim buna
1970'ler 60 lira gittiğimiz zaman bu
indekste daha gibi büyük şirketlerin
yaşamıyorum 15 yıla kadar ama günümüzde
doğru yaklaştıkça bu yaşadığın 20 yıl
öpüştüğü bundan sonrası için daha daha
kısalarak devam edileceğine dair de
eklentiler yani şirketleri hayatta
tutmak uzun süreli ayakta tutmak gittiği
için proje ji Peki şekilde önünü
kalmasın içerisinde birçok farklı
Merhaba bugünkü başımızda ölçü şarkısı
nedir derseniz o da aslında
özne olarak gitmelerine daim kıl almış
olmaları ilmi Hakikaten bu kadar elenmiş
i Şimdi sizlere yemeğim ediyoruz ama
tamamını sorsa dediğim çok kırıldı çok
farklı bakış açılarıyla çok güzel
tanımlar gelir ama Dilerseniz bugün
doğrudan da en büyük lideri çalışalım
bugün ödeme alma
bu Atatürk diyor ki bir insan hayatında
Büyük başarılar kazanmış olabilir ancak
yalnız Bunlar övünerek kalmak isterse o
başarılar the unutulmaya mahkumdur
Dolayısıyla daima çalışmak ve başarıya
aramak Her birimiz için esas gayesi
olmalıdır yemenin çok net çok sayıda
yoksa delikleri mı ile büyük ucu da
Evet şimdi ben sizlere getirdi email
için var Yazıldı Daha önceleri de
gelecek ama daha böyle sadeleştirici
hikayelerini dönüştürücü dursana plazma
indir geliyor somutlaştırmaya çalışalım
sizler için bunlar baktığınızda Biz
döner yaklaşır bir diğeri değişmiyor
etmek bir yeri a potansiyeli Asya
dönüştürmek
beklentilerin ötesine ne demek şimdi
böyle baktığınızda biraz işte tarafından
satılmamış değil mi
gençler
sizi daha iyi anlaması size daha olması
değişmeleri
bekliyorsun
ya da potansiyel
dönüştürmek içimizdeki heyecanı
paylaşmak istemiyor musunuz
dedim yani seni Her şey ortaya noktaları
var bireysel ve kurumsal yemeği maalesef
Çünkü burada bu büyük çarkı
çevirebilmek için ortada bir kırmızı
duymam ay arkadaşlar sana süper bir tane
Buraya koymuşlar aynısından O düğmeye
basmadan bu küçükken Örmeye başladım O
nedir derseniz o o o o
O benim mahalleden sonra hem meyve hem
değişik duruşta ilk tanıştığı dönem
1982 Yıl
İlkokulu beşi O zaman çok küçük bir
kasaba olan Alanya'da okuyorum o babamın
görevlilerimize ve
öğretmenimiz büyük fedakarlığı normal
Okuldan sonra bize tutuyor ve kendisi
bizi o dönemde gideceğiz hazırlandınız
Anadolu Liseleri ve kolejlere giriş
sırada hazırlamaya çalışıyorum Akşamları
çalışıyoruz iki saat üç saat
şöyle bir çarpıcı uygulaması vardır 1982
yılında arkadaşlar
bir kova anlatır soruyu sorar Ondan
sonra soruyu çözüp getiren ya da sorun
zorluğuna göre ilk 3 kişiye hediye
veririm
söylüyorlardı kediye testimiz vardı
Oraya çektikleri atılır Bu başarı
göstermiş
Yanılmaz Yarışıyor
uyuşturmaya rekabete icatlar 11 yaşında
Alanyalı ve o hediyeler her 25 tane
biriktikçe ve kendi aldığı kendi finanse
ettiği veriyoruz
125 adet de bisiklet alıyoruz vay
1980'li yıllar kaç yaşında istedi vardı
ki
ulaşabiliyor dua başarıya açtı ve
heyecanı öğrendik ama bir kural da vardı
abone ol Bu soru yanlış düzelirsin
konuyu anlamış olabilirsin ama bir şey
yaparsak yani o kazandığı başarı
şenliklerinden incir zorlukla kazandığı
başarı çeşitlerinden üçüde şiirden
yaptılar gidebilirsin geliyor kaybediyor
hediyeler de başarılar uzaklaşır Bu da
şu
Bu
arkadaşların konsantrasyonu bozar mı mı
onları yanlış yönlendirmek bir yaparsa
bilgilendiriniz de helal ettirmek için
de onlarla geciktiği için ya da soru
çözemediği için dalga geçer Sak
kaybetmeden uzaklaşır
dolayısıyla bir yaşında Küçücük çocuk ya
şunu öğrendiler hayatımda İyi veya metin
oluşturmak zorunda olacak Yaşam böyle
birşeymiş Ama her ne yaparsam yapayım
ediyor şunlar uzaklaşmadan yapmak
zorundayım O günlerden aldım ihtiyaçları
buydu bugünkü başladı vardır
Evet şimdi
bileşenleri biraz da soğuk taştığı
istiyorum sizler için Mesela dedi ki biz
döner bakışı şimdi Bununla ilgili
hayatınızda güzellikler eğitimden sonra
çıkmıştı gel çıkacak olan
bir vizyon Değişikliği var onu getirdim
sizler için yöneticiler hissettiği der
bakışı sıra dolu bilgiler Vizyon
üreticilerimiz profil sürekli
yönlendirir yağı yapma oraya git
yardımcı olur mu
bu oldukça kız yapılar vardır Diğeri
hiper bakış açısı motivasyonla oyun
sahası Ekip arkadaşlarıyla birlikte
oluşturur
bu herşeyi yanıtı vardır yönetici olmak
zorundadır tek Türk bir kişi her şeyi
bilebilir hastane zaman yanıt vermek
zorundadır yönetici bakış açısını
abone ol
o yanakları var cayder bakış açısından
güçlü soruları vardır durumu pozisyonu
riski fırsatları anlamak için belki ile
paylaşmak için
bu sorunların CG
bu ilkokul ortaokul izlemeni spa merkezi
bitirdim
bu iş görüşmelerine gitmeye başladı
E tabii şarj ateşimiz bir Türkiye'nin
çok büyük şirketlerden bir tanesi
görüşmeye çağırdı Sabah dokuzda randevu
verdi Pazartesi sabahı dokuz
heyecanla gittim Sabah 9'da da çok
görüşmeye gider adaylarda dedim de büyük
şirket Demek ki dedi mfc alıp yapacaklar
farklı farklı departmanlarda gibi 25
yıllar sonra biraz konuşuyor Oradakiler
de anladım ki farklı işleri de hepsini
benim pozisyona görüşmek için çağırmış
daha yakın mı
ama bence yavaş biraz da ya çektim Sağol
4'te iş görüşmesine geldim 7 saat sonra
bu içeriye girdim patron kocaman
masasında oturuyor görüşmeye defa sol
yapıyor insan kaynakları yöneticisi veya
bölüm yöresi değil doğrudan kendisi
onlar çok ilerledi
Bir de oturdum Evet de takıl dedi bizim
Şirketimize Neden çalışmak istiyorsun
soru bu
ne söylediğini de sağlık dedim ki bu
saate kadar Neden sizin şirketinizde
çalışmak istediğim Allah akışı değil Siz
tercih ettiğiniz dahil eden burada
çalışır heyecana aktarmak için bekledi
bakın dedim 25 tane geçti şöyle verdi
Bir tanesi hepsine dedim Sabah
kısaltıldı Var mısınız sağlar Saatlerdir
bekliyor ve benden sonra görüşeceğimiz
var ve iyi çalışan insana verdiğinizde
bunun masaları Bu da değiştiren bir şey
daha içeri girdim ve anlamak yerine
Hayallerim izliyorum geçmişi başarı
başarısı et almak yerine
yeter
kusura bakma benim böyle bir şekilde
çalışmak yüksük olamazdım
bu polis İndigo
kahkahaların olduğu salonda ben giderken
bu sesi bozan aç ve geldiğinde hafif
kafada değilim çıkıp kapasitesi
Dolayısıyla yönetici halde kötü bir
yönetici bir ortamda yaşamıştım yoğun
karar verdim ben temas ettiği
dokunduğumuz kimse Böylelikle iyikide
almışım
bu
işler görmek müthiş bir dönemdir bir
heyecan bu böyle birazcık değil yani
projeler amasyon dijital görüşün
sakatlar yatırımlar değişen bir
alışkanlıkları okumam araçlar kendi
kendine arkadaşlar elektrikli kamyonlar
çaldır Olmaz olmaz Bir dünyanın
içerisindeyiz biraz Kafanız bularak
Oradan doğru ödülleri çekip kendinize
uygun olan cebimize koyup yollarımızı
belirlemek ve eğlenmek için çabalıyoruz
kolay değil elde ettik Peki var içinde
olduğunuz buna dair hikaye derseniz
geçmişin hem de yaşadığım hikaye var Ben
kendi çalıştığım şirkette aynı zamanda
proje değerlendirme komitesi üyesi nedir
bu dersiniz içinde olmaktan büyük
mutluluk vereceğim Biliyorum bu şu an
çok değerli bir iş arkadaşlarım Siz Eğer
şirketimizde çalışan sadece geçti geç
düşme yaşansa da yani kalın
arkadaşlarımız oturuyorlar projeler
yapıyorlar herhangi bir fırsat değil
gördüklerim
oy oy geleceği müşteri talepleri Büyüme
stratejileri ve işi piyasaları ile
birlikte bir proje haline getirip sonum
yapıyorlar anlatılarak benim sizde
burada anlatmaya çalıştığım gibi
Oh bu işi nasıl 150 geleceğini
anlatıyorlar veya tığ Beste istiyorlar
Biz da
da aynı
girişimcileri Melek yatırımcılara götür
anlattığı projeler var ya kaynak almak
için kaynaklarında aynı şekilde büyük
heyecanlı anlatıyorlardı onlardan
öğreniyoruz onlarla birlikte ölüyoruz
bu Pamukçu örnekler var mı kişilik
tanesini eğitim olmaz mı çok var ticari
projeler karavan kiralama 37 sağlık
geçirdi çok sevdiği tane örnek
İyi günler o arkadaşlarımızın çalışıp
getirdikleri Ticaret projeleri sadece
iki tane örnek bize yaşıyor bu işler
hale geçtikten sonra bilmeden ayarla
tatile gitmek t
çok değerli öylesine Geçme Allah bizi
zor başlayayım evlenmek için
abone ol
O çok duymuş değil başladığımızda
Formula 1 ilmek hız değerine Evet bu
yönüyle çok öreceğim buradan size başka
bir hikaye anlatacağım arkadaşlar Okul
iş görüşmeleri ve yavaş yavaş işe
yaradığına tecrübe dönmeye başladı
Malatya'da görev yapıyor bilmiyorum
servis
serviste zaman zaman 120'ye Varan
girişleri çıkıyor 120 müşteri
araştırıyor izmet almak için Tabii
Özelde de böyle yükseldiği günlerde
arkadaşlar sorarlar kişi yetiştirilmek
ve kaliteli hizmet vardır ama ister
istemez müşteri sıraladığımız diyor ve
hücrelerde sıkılıyorlar
pazara formülleri yazacağız ya
bu pazartesi şirketteyim iki arkadaşın
topladım konuştuk bir pilot bir proje
yaptık
15 şiddeti oluşturduk kıyafetlerini
çarpıp Siz alet iki tane o an rengine
çizgisine kadar şapkalar dahi güneş
gözlükleri alıp etkiler oyuncu Leyla
yazdırmaya başladık Aslında giriş sıra
bunda olduğu sürece Evet davası
istediğimiz için bu
[Müzik]
şu an nesnedir
34 günleri eşim birlikte ararız sonra
sana
her zaman Oğlum niye uzatıyorsun
buraya gelmeden önce de aradım Yine aynı
şeyi söyle Oğlum neden uzatıyorsun beni
dedim ki anne yani
hayatımızda dedim olağanüstü değişimler
oluyor belki benim hayatımda oluyordur
dedi onu merak etmiyorsun dedi anne
dedim Hiçbir şey yaşındasın nasıl bir
heyecan Fırtınası hayatı olabilir
güçlükle bir şeyler değiliz ama beklenti
böyle
Dolayısıyla arkadaşlar Hayatımızın her
döneminde ister işte özel hep tekrar
ötesine göre etmek bizim sorumluluğumuz
ya da bildiğim için aracımız olacak
bu ev
orkestra formülle değil de de orada
gidiyoruz hadi çok beklemem yanı var bu
kesiyorum size 93 yılda işi telefon
kestiler
iki bulmaları
bir takım haline gelmek bireyler takıma
dönüşmek iyi beni Ana bileşenleri özür
bile şehirlerinden birisidir Arkadaşlar
bu kitaplarda çok güzel tarihleri var
ama
Ben Seni Tarihe dersin Ben şu
hissediyorum orkestra ile özleşir her
bir
enstrüman da uzman üstüne 30-40 tane düz
yine bir araya toplayıp ve en iyi
bildikleri eserleri çalmaları istedim
ortaya çıkan eseri ürün tüh
ve o bu insana da kalabalık ders
ama ne zaman bu iki Aynı sahip
içerisinde aynı notalara basma ya
başlasın O zaman bu insana ya da
kalabalığa
ortaya çıkan
böylesine büyük bir değişik
dönemlerde sizi tekrar bunu kaldıracak
olan
şeylerdir O da mı
bu Pozantı'ya asyonu dönüştürmek
Buradan da bir tek cep sizler için
arkadaşlar kariyer geliştirmek isterim
birer bazen kırdıkları yaşadığını
görüyorum geniş arkadaşlarına Eskiden
şöyle sorular vardı gidiyorum artık
yoktur iş görüşmesine gittiğinizde şöyle
bir soru gelebilir üç yıl sonra
kendinizi nerede görüyorsunuz
bilmiyorum
Size şirketimizin vizyonu Büyüme
stratejileri varsa kariyer ağacı kişisel
gelişim yap yatırılır Bilmiyorum ki 300
lira verdi bilmiyorum ama bilmeden
yaptım ama bir şey diyorum bir şey
istiyorsunuz
kişisel kendinize yatırım yaparsanız
bugün sonuçlarını Alacağız da nevi oldu
o yüzden iş yaşamı kişi potansiyellerini
ortaya çıkarmalarına fırsat veren vesile
olan bir kişisel değişim yolculuk
kendinize yatırım yaparsanız Emin olunuz
yukarıya gelişmesi olan sayısız kayar
masası o güzel yaşamınız boyunca farklı
zamanlarda farklı alanlarda önümüze
çıkacaktır bir sonuç olarak Evet
bu peki Şöyle bir tarifimiz var diye
bana sorarsanız bu kadar çalıştık olduğu
tablodan kendimize seçtiği yürümeye
başladı iyiyim Elendik beklentilerle
mücadele Şti aştı değişimi
gerçekleştirilir başarıdan Doruk noktası
ne dersiniz benim tarifi budur
isminizi bir bak Görürsün altına
koymaktan azaltmak Her işte
sürebilirmiyiz
zaman o yolculukta kazandığınız
deneyimler en zorlandığınız dönemlerde
sizin ışığınızı ve yol aydınlatıcı
olacaktır hem de oraya koymak lazım Peki
son olarak
çok küçük onlarla mücadele ederken en
zorlandığımız düştüm her
başarısız olduk zaman hiç olmayacak
bunlarla Baş edebilmek için yanınızda
birisi getirdiniz bir dersiniz getirdim
o gitti ruhudur
bu
başarısızlığı en güzel yanı farklı
çözümlerle tekrar benim için yeni bir
fırsat vermektir arkadaşlar
bu eğer o bacısı olduğunuz verenlerden
kazanımları yerinize koyuyorsunuz bir
yara çok daha güçlü bir şekilde yeni
fırsatınız var kuş sürede
başarı istenilen her daim yanınızda
olduğu arkaya enerji dolu yine doğru
yatıyorum hepimize sağlıkla kalın
sevgiyle dedim ya